[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قررت المحكمه الفلسطينيه العليا
اجراء الانتخابات المحليه المقبله في
الضفه الغربيه دون قطاع غزه وذلك بدعوه
عدم شرعيه المحاكم فيه وقد دت حركه
المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس القرار ووصفته
بالمسيسه طالبت لجنه الانتخابات المركزيه
بتاجيل الاقتراع سته اشهر وذلك لترتيب
البيت الفلسطيني الداخلي نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لكي نناقشه في
محورين هل تفسر الحيثيات القانونيه وحدها
قرار استبعاد قطاع غزه من الانتخابات
المحليه وما تاثير هذا القرار على م لف
الوحده الفلسطينيه وفرص الخروج من سنوات
[موسيقى]
الانقسام الناخبون في قطاع غزه لا يشاركوا
في الانتخابات المحليه المقبله لذلك قضت
محكمه العدل العليا قائله ان المحاكم هناك
ليست شرعيه ويوشك القرار ان يشكل هزه اخرى
في المشهد السياسي والاجتماعي الفلسطيني
قد تكون لها تداعيات على لف الانقسام
ومحاوله الخروج منه عبر مصالحه تبدو عصيه
حتى الساعه قرار قضائي تقول رام الله حيث
توجد السلطه الفلسطينيه الوطنيه بانه بل
مسيس تقول حركه حماس في غزه وبين الوصفين
مواقف قوى وفصائل فلسطينيه عده تخشى من ان
يزداد طين الخلافات الفلسطينيه بالله
تقرير فتحي
اسماعيل
مح لن تكون الانتخابات المحليه الفلسطينيه
قريبه ولا مشتركه بين الضفه وغزه كما كان
متوقعا لها فقد حسمت محكمه العدل العليا
في رام الله الجدله وقضت باجرائها في كافه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه عدا قطاع غزه دون
تحديد موعد لذلك وقد بررت المحكمه قرارها
بان المحاكم في القطاع لم تقدم الضمانات
اللازمه لاجراء تلك الانتخا
شعين بالسه لها وعليه فهم لا يمتلكون
صلاحيه اصدار الاحكام في الطعون المقدمه
اليهم بشان قوائم المرشحين يتعلق الامر
تحديدا بقرار كانت قد اصدرته المحكمه
الابتدائيه في خان يونس باسقاط خمس قوائم
لحركه فتح في القطاع لمخالفتها قانون
الانتخابات كما ذكر نص قرار جاء قرار
المحكمه العليا بعد قرار سابق كانت اتخذته
في الثامن من سبتمبر الماضي قضى بتعليق
العمليه الانتخابيه برمتها بعد ما كان
مزمعا اجراؤها في الثامن من اكتوبر الحالي
وبمعزل عن جوانبه القانونيه ووجهته من
عدمها يقوض القرار مسعى اجراء اول
انتخابات فلسطينيه مشتركه منذ عشر سنوات
ما يعني ان الوحده
لا تزال ينه الخلافات بين فتح
وحماس حماس التي لم تشارك في اي انتخابات
منذ تلك التي فازت فيها عام 2006 سارعت
الى التنديد بالقرار واعتبرته مسيسا ومكر
للانقسام بل وتمييز ضد غزه على حد
قولها لا يعرف ان كانت المحاكم والهيئات
القضائيه في القطاع والضفه قد اصبحت فعلا
ادوات للصراع وتصفيه الحسابات بين الخصوم
السياسيين لكن الواضحه انها لن تكون بمناى
عن تلك التجاذبات ضمن هذا السياق ربما
جاءت توصيه لجنه الانتخابات المركزيه
بتاجيل الانتخابات سته اشهر يتم خلالها
ترتيب البيت الداخلي الفلسطيني ومعالجه
الانظمه والقوانين ذات الصله كما قالت في
رسالتها الى الرئيس محمود عباس توصيه لكبح
تداعيات محتمله لقرار المحكمه العليا بعد
ان رات فيه اللجنه تاجيج للفرقه
والانقسام موضوعنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
غزه سامي ابو زهري المتحدث الرسمي باسم
حركه حماس ومن رام الله اسامه القواسمي
المتحدث الرسمي باسم حركه فتح ومن عمان
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
لحركه المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه اهلا
بكم جميعا سيد القواسمي قادك الحيثيات
القانونيه وحدها كافيه لتبرير استبعاد غزه
عن انتخابات المحليه شدر تعمل زوم شوي
لقدام
قواسمي اولا نحن غير ساعدين نحن غير
سعيدين بالمطلق بهذا القرار ونحن نريد
التاكيد على موقف حركه فتح الراغب منذ
البدايه ومنذ اللحظه الاولى والذي شجع
حركه فتح على ضروره التمسك بموعد
الانتخابات في 18 ع بعد ان قررت الحكومه
وموافقه حركه حماس على اجراء الانتخابات
لاننا قلنا منذ اللحظه الاولى ان تسع
سنوات عجاف من الانقسام الاسود الذي اضر
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه لعل موافقه حركه حماس
باجراء الانتخابات في قطاع غزه والضفه
الغربيه ان تكون بارقه امل وبوابه جديده
نحو تكريس الوحده الوطنيه والذهاب الى
انتخابات رئاسيه وتشريع الشعب الفلسطيني
في قطاع غزه هو الكاسر الخاسر الاكبر من
عدم اجراء او بناء على قرار المحكمه بعدم
اجراء انتخابات هناك ونحن غير راضين عن عن
هذا القرار القضيه الثانيه الخاسر الاكبر
الثاني هي حركه فتح اذ ان حركه حماس ادركت
منذ اللحظه الاولى بعد ان توحدت حركه فتح
بشكل كامل في قطاع غزه ان خسارتها ستكون
مدويه في القطاع لذلك هربت مباشره بعد
استعدادات حركه فتح الفاقع منقطعه النظير
على وجه الخصوص في قطاع غزه وقرت اللجوء
الى محاكمها غير الشرعيه باسقاط القوائم
لحركه فتح خمسه قوائم القضيه الثانيه او
الاخيره في هذا الموضوع لو ان حركه حماس
ارادت فع لهذه العمليه الديمقراطيه ان تتم
لحي محاكمها وذهبت الى انتخابات تنافس فيه
حركه فتح بعد اسقاط تسعه قوائم لحركه فتح
مع من تريد تتنافس حركه حماس في قطاع غزه
هي تريد ان تتنافس مع بالنسبه اليك القرار
غير مرحب بها او او لا يسعدكم على الاقل
ولكن تتحمل مسؤوليه حماس سامي ابو زهري
لديك
رد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
يعني للتذكير حركه حماس رحبت باجراء
الانتخابات رغم انها لم تستشر في هذه
الانتخابات ولم تتم بتوافق وطني عند اعلان
قرار الانتخابات حركه حماس تسلمت مذكره
رسميه من رئيس لجنه الانتخابات المركزيه
الدكتور حنا ناصر ابلغ فيه الحركه ب من
خلال هذا الكتاب الخطي ان الانتخابات
ستجري من خلال القضاء والامن الموجود في
غزه والضفه واعلن ذلك في عده مؤتمرات
صحفيه واعلن ذلك امام الفصائل الفلسطينيه
ولم يعترض ايا من الفصائل في ذلك الوقت
بما في ذلك حركه فتح حركه فتح اعترضت فقط
لاحقا حينما خسرت بعض قوائمها في قطا في
قطاع غزه وانا اريد ان اشير الى ان الذي
اسقط قوائم حركه فتح ليس المحاكم في غزه
قبل المحاكم لجنه الانتخابات المركزيه
اسقطت اربعه قوائم لحركه فتح بسبب عد عدم
استيفائها للشروط الانتخابيه ثم المحاكم
الموجوده في غزه قبلت رفض قبلت الطعون في
اربعه مجالس بلديه ورفض طعون في سبع مجالس
بلديه اي انه لم تقبل معظم الطعون في غزه
ولذلك الذي اسق القوائم هو عدم استيفائها
للشروط الانتخابيه المشكله هنا الى ان
حركه فتح رفضت الاحتكام للمحاكم الموجوده
في غزه رغم ان القانون قانون الهيئات
الانتخابيه ينص على ان محاكم البدايه في
غزه والضفه هي المختصه بالنظر في الطعون
ولجات حركه فتح الى المحكمه العليا التي
لم يرد في اي نص من قانون الهيئات المحليه
اي اشاره الى دور هذه المحكمه و اناا اريد
ان اشير الى ان الخلاف في موضوع القضاء
والامن هو خلاف سياسي وليس خلافا اداريا
وهذا ما يجعلنا نرفض تدخل المحكمه العليا
اذا المساله كانت مساله قانونيه فان محمود
عباس با هو اول من سيطعن في شرعيته عمليا
مده ولايته القانونيه انتهت رئيس الحكومه
الفلسطينيه لم يحظى بالثقه من المجلس
التشريعي نحن امام حاله سياسيه اس
استثنائيه تدار بالتوافق الوطني وكان على
المحكمه العل العليا مراعاه ذلك واريد ان
اضيف الى ان هذه المحكمه حتى لو حق لها
النظر اداريا في هذا الموضوع فانها تعاملت
بتسييس حقيقي لانه احد اسباب وقف
الانتخابات هو وان الذريعه هو ان القدس
غير مشموله في هذه الانتخابات اليوم هذه
المحكمه تصدر قرارا باستكمال الانتخابات
في الضفه رغم ان القدس بقيت خارج
الانتخابات اذا هذا يدلل على ان القرار في
تمييز في تسييس والا لو كانت القصه قصه
القدس لعطل انتخابات بعيدا عن انتقائيه
وعطلت في كل في غزه والضفه كما هي معطله
في القدس دكتور البرغوثي كنتم اول من
اعترض على اقتراح تاج جيل الانتخابات عند
عند بدايه الحديث عن الانتخابات اليوم
يعني ع على ما ارتكزت حتى تقولوا يجب
اجراء هذه الانتخابات طالما على ما يبدو
انه طريقه تحضيرها لم تنضج كفايه والدليل
ما حدث والان اطيح بها كلها
لبل رسخ
الانقسام طبعا احنا اعترضنا من البدايه
على قرار المحكمه الاول واعترض اليوم على
قرار المحكمه الثاني وبصراحه وبملء الفم
اقول للاسف الشديد هذه القرارات لا مبرر
قانوني لها الحجج القانونيه التي سيقت غير
مقنعه نحن نعتقد ان القرار سياسي بامتياز
ودوافعه سياسيه ومن غير المقبول ان يسيس
القضاء القضاء يجب ان يكون فوق العوامل
السياسيه وانا ب فصل لي اين التسيس اولا
الحجز القانونيه التي استعملت ام طبعا
لانه ان واضح اولا كيف يحرم اهل قطاع غزه
بكامله من المشاركه في الانتخابات يعني
بدي اذكر شيء مضحك مدينه غزه لم تجري فيها
انتخابات بلديه منذ عام
1946 هل يجوز ذلك اجلت عام 2005 واجلت
لعام 2006 لاسباب سياسيه وجرت الانتخابات
في كل المحلات الا في مدينه غزه واليوم
يراد ايضا ان تؤجل في كل قطاع غزه هذا
دافع سياسي مش مش قانوني الدوافع
القانونيه التي ق قيل اولا موضوع القدس
طيب اليوم ما بدها تجري في القدس وكمان في
قطاع غزه لو كان هذه حجه قانونيه بسبب عدم
اجرائها في غزه يجب ان تجري في اي محل
وبالتالي هذه الحجه غير مقنعه الحجه
الثانيه الاختلاف في المحاكم ما كان معروف
عندما اصدرت المحكمه الحكومه قرارها
باجراء الانتخابات وكان معروف عندما ذكرت
ذلك لجنه الانتخابات المركزيه وكان معروف
عندما وقعت القوى الفلسطينيه كلها ميثاق
الشرف انا برايي كان ممكن عزل القضيه اذا
كانت القضيه هي الخمس مجالس التي اخذت
المحكمه براي البعض قرارا مجحفا بحقها كان
ممكن تاجيل الانتخابات في هذه الخمس مجالس
واستكمالها في كل الضفه الغربيه وغزه
لماذا نعاقب 417 موقع كان ممكنا ذلك
قانونيا يعني معالجه الاشكاليات في
المواقع التي وقعت فيها فقط وليس حرمان كل
غزه من ذلك من
الانتخابات بالضبط وفي نقطه مهمه هذا
القرار خطير
لانه لما بتقولي كل شيء في المحاكم في غزه
غير قانوني يعني بالله كل القرارات اللي
اخذت في قضايا الطلاق والزواج طول العش
سنين غير قانونيه يعني كل القرارات اللي
اخذت في موضوع التعليم غير قانوني يعني
نتائج التوجيهي طول 10 سنين غير قانونيه
القضايا التي تتعلق بالصحه غير قانونيه
يعني هذا القرار مسيس غير مسؤول وخطير
وبتالي لا يجوز ابدا ان نقبل الان بعد ان
قطعنا خطوه في اتجاه الانتخابات المشتركه
فيغ نحو انهاء الانقسام اسسمي اسامه
القواسمي القرار سياسي مسيس غير مسؤول
خطير كل شيء كما قال الدكتور البرغوثي
سيكون مشكوك بامره ان قبلتم بقرار المحكمه
هذه بناء على ما اعتبرته المحكمه بانه
قضاء غير شرعي وغير مخول البث بها يعني كل
من تزوج بغزه امام هذا القضاء سوف يكون
زواجه ايضا حرام بالنسبه اليكم اذا كنتم
قد قبلتم بقرار المحكمه
العليا لا لا لا الزواج حلال تحديدا
الزواج حلال لانه بغض النظر بدون عقد كمان
مجرد الاشهار والقبول والايجاب حل في قطاع
غزه وفي كل مكان حسب غير الزواج بقيه
العقود موضوع في في موضوع في في فيما فيما
يتعلق بما صرح به الاخ مصطفى البرغوتي وال
الناطق باسم حركه حماس اعتقد عندما يقول
انه مسيسا فانا اريد ان يجيبوني من على
قناه الجزيره لمصلحه من تم التسييس اذا
كان وجهه نظرهم ان القياده الفلسطينيه او
حركه فتح هي من ضغطت على المحكمه اعتقد ان
هذا ليس له علاقه بالصحه لا من قريب ولا
من بعيد لعده اسباب اولا القضاء مستقل
تماما ولا علاقه لاي احد بالقضاء
الفلسطيني وقد جرب في الكثير من المرات
بقرارات مخالفه للتوجهات السياسيه اما اذا
كان مسيسا فنحن نقول اذا كان مسيسا نحن
نريد اجراء الانتخابات في قطاع غزه نحن
الخاسرون في حركه فتح فلماذا نضغط على شيء
ليس له ع بمصلحتنا نحن في قطاع غزه فائزون
بالانتخابات 100% وحركه حماس هي التي
افشلت الانتخابات من خلال الاعتقالات التي
بدات وعندما فشلت في كل الذرائع ذهبت الى
قضيه اسقاط قوائم انتم تحدثتم بشكل واضح
اسمح لي انت تقول حركه فتح هي الخاسره من
عدم اجراء الانتخابات في غزه باستطاعتها
ان تعترض ان تنقض قرار المحكمه هذا واصلا
يعني ربما قد يكون قول لك دكتور برغوثي
وحتى السييد سامي ابو زهري الكل خسران في
هذه القصه اذا لما لا يجري عمل شيء تجاهه
الكل خسران كل الشعب الفلسطيني خسران حتى
لجنه الانتخابات يا سيدي لجنه الانتخابات
طلبت من الرئيس رجته بان يؤجل هذه
الانتخابات عندما تعمد لجنه الانتخابات
الى التماس لدى الرئيس هذا يعني بيده ان
يفعل
شيئا انتظروا الرئيس وننتظر ماذا يفعل
ولكن حتى اوضح تفنيد ما قاله الدكتور
مصطفى البرغوتي وسامي ابو زهري معارض
ومخالف للحقيقه تماما لاننا نحن في حركه
فتح الدافع الاساسي الذي جعلنا نتشجع الى
الانتخابات هو اجراءها في قطاع غزه والضفه
الفلسطينيه وقلنا منذ البدايه لعلها تكون
فاتحه امل وشره وبشاره خير للجميع ان نكرس
الوحده الوطنيه نحن من نريد الانتخابات
نحن من اخذنا قرارا بضروره اجراء
الانتخابات الديمقراطيه نحن الانتخابات لم
تتوقف طيله تسع سنوات
منط غزه م اعطيني موقفا يعني انت انت
متحدث رسمي باسم حركه فتح اريد منك موقفا
الان في هذا البرنامج للجزيره ول يعطيني
حلا لهذا الموضوع طالما انت تعترف الان
بانه من مصلحه فتح ان تجرى الانتخابات في
غزه من اجل هذه المصلحه مصلحه فتح تحديدا
كيف يعني ما ما الذي ستفعلون كيف ستواجهون
قرار المحكم
بحيث تربحون وتجرى الانتخابات في غزه
لمصلحه
فتح عده نقاط اولا نحن القضاء مستقل
ونحترم القضاء ونحن لدينا قرار بضروره
اجراء الانتخابات في الضفه الغربيه وفي
قطاع غزه هناك توصيه من لجنه الانتخابات
لسيد الرئيس هي ليست جهه توصي وانما جهه
تنفيذيه مع اننا نشكرهم على هذه التوصيه
الايجابيه لان لها علاقه بالصالح العام
ونحن نريد الوحده الوطنيه مع حركه حماس
بين الضفه وقطاع غزه لا نريد ان نكون
بقايا داحس والغبراء كما يفعلون اهلنا في
قطاع غزه واقصد حركه حماس للاسف الشديد
لذلك اللجنه
المركزيه اجل ت اشكرك ساعود اليك بعد
الفاص بقولك لا ستقل لي بعد الفاصل ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد دكتور برغوثي
عوده سريعه اليك مع نص البيان تحديدا الذي
تلاه هشام الحتو الصادر عن المحكمه التي
قضت باستبعاد غزه من الانتخابات تقول
المحكمه تصادق على تنفيذ قرار مجلس
الوزراء القاضي باجراء الانتخابات المحليه
في كافه الهيئات في فلسطين ما عدا قطاع
غزه اذا المحكمه تصادق على قرار مجلس
الوزراء يعني مجلس الوزراء باعتقادك
قانونيا هل باستطاعته ان يفعل شيئا
بالقانون
حتى يجري التراجع عن قرار المحكمه بناء
على هذا النص انا اكلت في
سؤالي اولا بس بدي ارد على الاخ القواسمه
من مصلحتنا جميعا ان لا نفصل بين غزه
والضفه الغربيه ومن مصلحتنا جميعا ان تجري
انتخابات حره نزيهه تتيح للشعب الفلسطيني
حق المشاركه وتفتح الطريق لاجراء انتخابات
رئاسيه وتشريع وللمجلس الوطني ولكن اليوم
حركه حماس اعترضت على قرار المحكمه والقو
التحالف الديمقراطي يعني المبادره الوطنيه
والجبهه الشعبيه والديمقراطيه وفد وحزب
الشعب اعترضت على قرار المحكمه فل تعترض
ايضا حركه فتح لماذا لا يعترضوا على
القرار ويقولوا هذا قرار لا يتناسب مع
المصلحه الوطنيه ومع المصلحه الديمقراطيه
اليوم لجنه الانتخابات مضطره يعني في ثلاث
هيئات تستطيع ان تعالج المشكله الحكومه
تستطيع ان تقرر انه لا تريد ان تجل
الانتخابات في الضفه دون غزه وبالتالي
تتخذ اجراءات قضائيه وقانونيه ممكن تتاجل
الانتخابات شهر ش شهرين مع انه نحن لا نحب
ان تتاجل يوم واحد ولكن اذا كان هذا هو
الحل المؤلم وهذا ابغض الحلال فليكن على
شرط ان تجري الانتخابات في الضفه وغزه دون
تمييز ودون استثناء ودون حرمان اهل غزه من
المشاركه لجنه الانتخابات اوصت بذلك مجلس
الوزراء يستطيع ان يتخذ هذا القرار الاخ
الرئيس يستطيع ان يتخذ هذا القرار هناك
طريقه لمعالجه المشكله وانا لو عاد الامر
لي لقلت احصروا المشكله في الاربع خمس
مواقع واجرها في موعدها في ال
417 موقع اخر لماذا نحرم 417 مجلس بلدي
وقرو من حقهم من اجل 54 واقع فيها مشكله
لكن المدخل يجب ان يكون كان هناك حل مدخل
وطني مصلحه ديمقراطيه هذا ما يجب ان يحترم
طيب سيد سامي ابو زهري كيف ستتعامل مع هذا
الوضع هل تتوقع ان يتحرك الرئيس باتجاه
التراجع عن هذا القرار ان كان باستطاعته
ذلك
قانونيا
يعني حماس تجري مشاورات مع القوى
الفلسطينيه لمواجهه هذا القرار لانه قرار
خطير للغايه عمليا الذي كان الذين كانوا
يتهمون حماس بانها هي التي تمارس الانقسام
والتجزئه اليوم اتضح من الذي يجزئ ومن
الذي يفرض الانقسام بين غزه والضفه بهذا
القرار الخطير وغير المسبوق هناك لقاء يوم
غد بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه هنا في غزه
لمناقشه تداعيات هذا الموضوع والخروج ب
صيات ونحن معنيون بان يكون هناك موقف وطني
رافض لهذا القرار المسيس واتخاذ اجراءات
للخروج من هذه الازمه لكن دعيني اشير الى
نقطه مهمه في موضوع القضاء الموجود في غزه
الذي يسمى بانه غير شرعي هناك نقابه
محامين هذهه النقابه فازت فيها حركه فتح
بمعنى كل اعضاء النقابه المحامين في قطاع
غزه هم اعضاء في حركه فتح هذه النقابه
تترافع يوميا امام الض في غز سؤالي هو عن
فضول ال لا يوجد هناك فراغ قانون سؤالي عن
عن فضول يعني كيف ستتعامل يعني كيف يمكن
التعامل مع هذا القرار بان كل قضاء غزه
غير شرعي حنا ناصر عندما التقى بكم في
يوليو وفي اغسطس وتحدثت عن الانتخابات هذا
الرجل جاء من الضفه عندكم وتحدثت بالموضوع
هل اشار باي طريقه من الطرق الى ان قضاء
قضاء غزه غير شرعي لماذا
الان اص اصبح القضاء غير شرعي لا لا لا
المساله على العكس من ذلك تماما على العكس
من ذلك ت انا حضرت معظم اللقاءات التي جرت
مع الدكتور حنا ناصر اللقاءات مع قياده
الحركه اللقاءات مع الفصائل الفلسطينيه
الدكتور حنا ناصر كان واضحا ان الانتخابات
ستجري في غزه والضفه بالقضاء والامن في
غزه والقضاء مؤسسات القضاء والامن في
الضفه واعلن ذلك في مؤتمرات صحفيه واعلن
ذلك في لقاء مع الفصائل في غزه وكنت حاضرا
فيه وكان حاضر الاخ ابراهيم ابو النجا
القيادي في حركه فتح لم يكن هناك اي
اعتراض في في حينه اليوم بعد ان سقطت بعض
قوائم فتح لعدم استفاء شروط قامت القيامه
وبدا الحديث عن القضاء لما هناك عمليه لا
يوجد فراغ قانوني في غزه نقابه المحامين
هي نقابه من الاخوه في فتح وهي تترافع يوم
يوميا امام القضاء وبالتالي حجه حركه فتح
انها لا تعترف بشرعيه القضاء في غزه هذه
هذه حجه ساقطه وغير قائمه عمليا وانا اريد
ان اشير الى ان خطاب حركه فتح انه لا
علاقه لها بالقرار المحكمه وانها اصلا غير
مرتاحه لهذا القرار هذا من الناحيه
العمليه غير حقيقي لانه فتح لم تصدر قرارا
مثل بقيه الفصائل انها ترفض قرار المحكم
السيد قواس عن هذا
الموضوع ان الذي رف رفض ان الذي رفض الطعن
ام عفوا لحظه ان الذي قدم طعن امام
المحكمه العليا هي حركه فتح ولو لم تفعل
ذلك لكانت المركبه تسير بشكل طبيعي استاد
القواسمي لماذا لم يشمل اعتراض الفصائل
فتح ايضا على قرار المحكمه بشكل سريع لان
لدي بعض الاسئله والوقت اقترب على انتهاء
لماذا
لم فتح تصدر موقفا واضحا اذا كنت كما تقول
في البدايه اذا كانت
معترضه انا موقفي على الجزيره انا موقفي
على الجزيره واضح نحن غير راضين وسنعمل كل
جهدنا من اجل اجراء الانتخابات في الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه وكل الحكي الحكا ابو
زهري من الايه للياء من الالف الى الياء
كله كلام مخالف تماما للحقيقه والواقع انا
بس بدي اضرب نموذج
بصي بعيدا عن التعميم قواس هو هو لم يتهجم
ولم يفتري ولم يعطي حادثه يعني تحدث عن
نقابه المحامين فيها فتح ام لا نقابه
المحامين فيها فتح ام لا الذين
فازوا بس انت طيب خلص يا غاده بعرف انت
ميولك بس خليني اكمل جملتي لو سمحتي الله
يخليك
ح في الشخص انا يعني تنتهي الحلقه بطريقه
بشعه المستفيد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اجبني
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مستفيد من هذا ام لا
هذا ليس يعني هذا هذا ليس ميول اعتقد هذا
سؤال صحفي مستفيد ام لا طيب عظيم طالما
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مستفيد فح ما الذي
ستقدمه يا اخت
غاده طيب اخت غاده انا بتكلم لغه عربيه
فصحى واعتقد انه كلامي واضح نحن لسنا مع
قرار استثناء قطاع غزه نحن نسع لذلك
المطلوب من حركه حماس حتى تجري الانتخابات
ونتقرب اكثر ونصبح اخوه ونذهب الى
انتخابات رئاسيه وتشريع وتكرس الديمقراطيه
يقيموا القرارات المحاكم تبعتهم هم عطوا
الاوامر لهات ي كل المسؤوليه على حماس
دكتور برغو كيف سيتا ملف الوحده
الفلسطينيه بناء على هذا الموضوع دكتور
برغو اعطيتك فرصه سيد قواسمي دكتور برغوث
انهي معك
للاسف على الوحده كيف نعم للاسف
للاسف يؤثر بشكل سلبي جدا لانه للاسف ه
الانتخابات لو جرت بشكل طبيعي في موعدها
لكانت اول انتخابات تجري مرتين في تاريخ
الشعب الفلسطيني في نفس الوقت اكتفي بهذا
القدر اذا
يثر جدا انتهى الوقت للاسف هذا يا يا سيد
قواسم هذا موقف دكتور برغوثي وميوله واضحه
بالنسبه اليك على ما اعتقد شكرا جزيلا على
اي حال مروان الكتور مروان البرغوثي
الامين العام لحركه مبادره الوطن
دكتور مصطفى البرغوتي الامين العام لحركه
المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه شكرا جزيلا
لك واشكر ايضا سامي ابو زهري من غزه
واسامه القواسمي من رام الله واشكر
متابعتكم الى اللقاء باذن
[موسيقى]
الله